[Music]
Jordan yes good to see you good to see
you
stand up fine there's a rumor on staff
that you have not planned a bachelor
party
yeah I chose to avoid a bachelor party
Wow
I appreciate the sentiment rooted in
history however I always feel like I
don't identify with the current bachelor
party traditions
okay bruger in history what are you
talking about well I mean the bachelor
party goes back to ancient Sparta for
Christ who knows that did you look it up
I know these things you've not had a
bachelor party that's correct
okay do have friends and stuff I do do
you really have friends I've never seen
you with anybody do you with me do you
have friends name one quick first name
you
no it's gonna be fun I because I decided
that you should have a bachelor party
okay surprise excited about that I'm
indifferent I don't know what's in store
I'm not a big fan of humiliation and not
accumulating the money so then I
humiliate you
well I want you to have the classic
experience of having a bachelor party so
you wanna have a bachelor party yes you
won't have a bachelor party
look into camera and say you're excited
to have a bachelor party I've been told
to say I'm excited so let's get it
started would you like a drink I would
like a sparkling water with a high
mineral content because it's one of the
few naturally carbonated water favorites
it's your night I want you to be happy
bring it in this machine yeah yeah yeah
just do it yeah
that doesn't seem fun I was having fun
yeah that moment we just had was the
most fun I've ever had with you what's
next what's next yes there he is
DJ Christian in the house crikey
go
now he's using disco music I personally
prefer uncompressed digital
Wayne file or a IMS file problem is
maybe an 256 kilobits per second
variable but I still prefer
[Music]
let's take this party up another notch
please
now I know that you don't have friends
so I thought you were real bachelor
party friend set set say you I have
known each other for a long time let's
pretend okay remember George's nickname
[Applause]
let's crank it up we're killing
ourselves for you and you sipped your
Jager you threw away your cigar pretty
quickly you stared at your old friend
Nick you haven't danced you haven't done
anything it's supposed to be a bachelor
party I think it's time to go to the
next level next
[Music]
big Abigail is an attractive woman
however I don't think this situation is
conducive to sexual arousal I might have
something that's more Jordan speed
[Music]
[Applause]
I did my best
I appreciate them give you a great
bachelor party and then just put his
testicles in my face how did it feel
team this time
[Music]
[Applause]
my tip here good hey thanks for watching
please subscribe to my youtube channel
so they will stop making me shoot these
videos please